[Music]
i appreciate it thank you very much i uh
i hope this will be our last show with
masks i think because we have a hiatus
next week when we come back i think
so that's great and i'm so glad you're
in a good mood because a lot of heavy
news right going on in the world now a
lot of [ __ ] we gotta talk about tonight
and you know there's war in europe and
uh you know we did we didn't think this
would happen but then we thought it
would not happen but putin god damn it
he did it he invaded ukraine and that's
it between putin
and a school kid in america with putin
eventually the mask comes off
[Applause]
we learned a lot about the russians this
week do not make their figure skaters
cry
but i i mean you got to feel for these
poor people in ukraine i mean they are
now being forced into a world they do
not want any part of kind of kind of the
way i feel about the metaverse
[Applause]
yeah this uh
putin he ain't played this this
[ __ ] right i mean he he said he
had to do it because he thought that
ukraine was
going to acquire wmds pathetic
what kind of superpower makes up [ __ ]
like that
[Applause]
no he said putin putin said the other
day when he invaded he said uh if we
butt in
we're gonna see consequences like we've
never seen in history i don't know what
that means but the joke's on him because
we don't know any history
[Applause]
and if you don't well
if you know that's what i'm here for
and the reason why russia so pissed off
about this and things they are justified
to invade is because ukraine used to be
part of the soviet union which fell 30
years ago and now ukraine wants to join
nato you know and this makes russia
crazy
look for those of you who only know me
from the clips they show on
tmz thank you harvey for that
it's like russia is kanye
[Applause]
the
ukraine is kim kardashian
i know
nato was pete davidson and
it just
it just drives russia crazy
today they demanded billy eilish
apologize to travis scott i mean i don't
know
[Applause]
but it's interesting the way this war is
now dividing the parties even among
themselves uh the republicans one in
four republicans in who they blame
not putin biden
they play biden
biden
biden also made them impotent
and uh
he makes mexican music play on the radio
too much and
once a day he dresses as a small dog and
shits on their lawn that's
he's a very bad guy
you